[Music]
I totally screwed up PETA has put her
trust in me that I can handle her
choreography and I've asked her to push
me I feel bad because I feel like I let
pita down jarrow and Kyo Nick and pita
on this third week of competition the
couple leaving right now is Charo and
Kido
[Music]
exhale now breathe a little sigh of
relief yes I mean luckily we didn't go
home tonight so I saw the look where you
kind of gave him this look like what in
the hell we were laughing because I was
like we might be in the bottom two you
know be prepared and then they said okay
I was like kind of a Bedford but not so
I know I'm sorry Nick and cheetah were
you prepared to be in the bottom two
Nick I'm pretty much prepared for
anything so is the question already
tonight what do we do to improve next
week i mean i'm always looking to get
better right so that's regardless of
what the judges say as long as I'm still
here i'm going to try to get better and
hopefully i will and and still you just
enjoy this experience were you
frustrated tonight at all i mean i was
actually really excited about the
performance I mean certainly I think we
both hope for better scores but we can't
control that so I think what we can
control is getting back at it tomorrow
and trying to get better and go from
there
[Music]
you